.
THAT THE CHINESE JUST FORGAVE.
DO YOU REALLY THINK THE CHINESE
WOULD JUST FORGIVE A $5 MILLION
LOAN IF THEY WEREN'T GETTING
SOMETHING BIG OUT OF IT?
REALLY?
THEY WERE GETTING JOE BIDEN.
HUNTER MAY HAVE BEEN THE BAG MAN
OF THE WHOLE OPERATION BUT JOE
WAS THE ONE RUNNING THE SHOW
ACCORDING TO TONY BOBULINSKI.
SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY IS THE
ONE LEADING THE INVESTIGATION
INTO THE BIDEN FAMILY.
HE HAS BEEN HEARING DIRECTLY
FROM WHISTLEBLOWERS AND HE JOINS
US NOW.
SO I KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO TO
FOLLOW THE FACTS, SENATOR.
I MAY BE GETTING AHEAD OF
THINGS.
I KNOW YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE
GETTING AHEAD OF THINGS.
WHERE DO WE STAND RIGHT NOW AND
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THE
LETTER LAYS IT OUT PRETTY CLEAR.
WE HAVE SEEN DOCUMENTS THAT
THESE WHISTLEBLOWERS HAVE SHOWN
US.
WE HAVE READ THEM.
MY TEAM HAS GONE THROUGH THEM
THOROUGHLY.
AND WE KNOW WHAT THERE IS AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI.
AND SO OUR LETTERS ARE TO GET
THEM TO LET THEM KNOW WHAT WE
KNOW.
AND TO GET THEM TO TELL US WHAT
THEY ARE DOING WITH IT, IF
ANYTHING.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO EMBARRASS
THEM IN TO SAYING, TO DO THEIR
JOB.
AND THE PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT TO
KNOW THIS.
WHAT I HEAR IN IOWA IS THAT
PEOPLE ARE SICK AND TIRED OF THE
UNEQUAL APPLICATION OF THE LAW.
AND YOU HEAR -- YOU SEE THIS IN
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE
FBI WITH THIS HUNTER CASE
THROUGHOUT.
>> Jesse: IF YOU HAVE EVIDENCE
FROM WHISTLEBLOWERS THAT SHOW
THAT THE FBI IS SITTING ON
EVIDENCE THAT MAY DIRECTLY
INVOLVE CRIMINALLY THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES, AND THEY
ARE NOT DOING ANYTHING ABOUT IT,
HOW BIG IS THIS THING GETTING?
>> WELL, LISTEN, THE DOCUMENTS
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
AND I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THEIR
RESPONSE TO IT IF IT INVOLVES
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, THE PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT
TO KNOW THAT BUT WE ASK THESE
QUESTIONS WITH THESE AND OTHER
INSTANCES OF OUR INVESTIGATION.
WE GET NO ANSWER.
CONGRESS IS ENTITLED TO THIS
ANSWER.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE ENTITLED
TO THIS ANSWER.
AND THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF MY
LETTER.
>> Jesse: IF, IN FACT, JOE
BIDEN, AS VICE PRESIDENT OR AS
PRESIDENT OR BEFORE HE BECAME
PRESIDENT, WAS DOING SOMETHING
ILLEGAL AND WAS BEING BRIBED OR
COMPROMISED BY FOREIGN
NATIONALS, OUR ENEMIES, AND THE
FBI WAS PROTECTING HIM, FOLLOW
ME HERE,.
>> I WISH I COULD TELL YOU FOR
CERTAIN.
>> Jesse: BUT WHAT WOULD THAT
MEAN IF YOU TOOK OVER IN THE
SENATE, WHAT WOULD THAT LEAD YOU
TO DO AS A LEADER IN THE SENATE?
>> WELL, LET ME SAY THIS: IF
WE'RE IN THE MAJORITY, I'LL BE
CHAIRMAN OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
AND WHETHER -- IN THAT POSITION,
I THINK YOU'RE IN A STRONGER
POSITION TO DEMAND ANSWERS TO
YOUR QUESTIONS.
THEY SEEM TO IGNORE RANKING
MEMBERS OR MEMBERS OF THE
MINORITY PARTY.
THAT ISN'T RIGHT.
BUT THAT'S THE WAY IT IS.
AND AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE, I INTEND TO FOLLOW
THE FACTS AND THE MONEY WHERE IT
LEADS ME.
BUT I INTEND TO DO THAT EVEN IF
I'M NOT CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE, BECAUSE THAT'S MY
REPUTATION OF FOLLOWING THE
FACTS AND THE MONEY UNTIL I GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
AND THIS IS JUST ONE MORE STEP.
AND WE HAVE GOT SOUND
INFORMATION FROM THE
WHISTLEBLOWERS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF THESE DOCUMENTS
AND THEY SHOW A BAD THINGS AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE ENTITLED
TO KNOW WHAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING WITH THAT.
>> Jesse: YEAH.
WE SURE ARE ENTITLED TO THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
FOLLOWING THE MONEY.
I THINK WE ALL KNOW WHERE IT'S
GOING TO LEA